today all day busy slap it really lovely
here McIlwain
I'm Tom Geisel I've got a chronic
[Music]
rhinitis like a visible audacity with
clarity hustle like my name is Jerry
Thomas I've been telling you
accountability i'm tripoli given a
pedigree to be enough pleasure life sot
including the works and i'm gern are the
move of furniture I'm gonna make this a
binary conversation of either you
believe in me or not which will be good
for us the dollars impact the end and
just the brain power that for this and
and really to understand what this
actually even means to that was
something that I think may echo that I
am we have a lot of work to do we have
to like build the database but we're
there in a real way it's really cool and
it's actually be majorly impactful in
our business and it will work and you're
right three instead of one that come
over the win we're going to walk in and
say hey you're making us pitch for this
video to let us tell you something we're
going to give you two real big ones that
are straight up here's a here's a video
that they thought would they people
these will say that palma you're gonna
get six micros don't forget everything's
a chess move for us to be the full monty
you know every day that goes by gets
more and more intriguing will get bigger
we do this right that's it that's the
gospel religion every second
okay such a pleasure
[Music]
[Music]
nobody coming close to where I really
wanna be I'm busy working day and night
I'll never stop like they reveal so you
see everything clearly well great to see
you my friend
of course it's this new generation of
I'm just going to give my my you know
bubblegum startup 245 influencers are
into the great like it's a million here
three million there 9 million here six
million here two million minute super
circle it's done you know how in
parallel they're going to continue to
grow the private label business continue
to squeeze you for more brand dollars
it's not sustainable right seaman
ex-girlfriends criticism I remember the
conversation I'm ready to rock and roll
ready yeah give me context like not
going to have what yes degree what I'm
saying is you need to talk culture what
does that mean that means that if this
is your religion of building this
business that when the women's March
happened you guys would sit there go
holy [ __ ] there's a women's March
happening in two weeks right
I get you know I've done a couple of can
we play and you may say we can't we want
to stay away from Paula it doesn't
matter your your mindset as a strategy
team is we can be something someday that
will fundamentally change our business
and people don't do that and it's not
smart it's Ben and Jerry's like all the
companies like Godiva they all have
historically had these moments the Pepsi
challenge like look boy sparkling water
with the girls wearing that's actually
Instagram actually look like you have to
think that way if it's your mindset
it's your mindset got it you can't be a
digital brand you need to build a
business
[Music]
you saw Jerry something good to see a
few beautiful Corey Georgia Corey
garrison San Francisco was reviewing but
if you can hit scale like I have then
you got ungodly leverage yeah
but in case you haven't noticed you're
in this office and everyone else in your
kitchen yeah but guess what I was in
some [ __ ] conference room seven
years ago like you got to decide how
good you are aim this yeah totally get
it what do I roll the dice or maybe at
the optics I disappointed no what I
would tell you in order to tell you
actually because I didn't know how to
answer this I probably tell you to go
through it so that you come out the
other end with knowing because otherwise
you'll never but the space is right this
space is the wheel of space going
you just might you just have to figure
out how talented you are and like were
you early and got the benefit I feel
like I've started this before a king
like I got on this before it became like
this big of a trend
yeah Amaya ten years ago but like it was
right before really took off that's what
you think today and some kid that looks
like you that starts today is going to
say the same thing to me in 24 months
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this episode - 47 of the askgaryvee
show
my name is florida cliana i am from new
bern Massachusetts well I'm everyone
calls me cute took my blood all right Q
I've got a very important question
please are you a Patriots fan of course
I'm a favorite friend I'm sorry alright
q I had to do it to you but I promise
you that I will call you back on
time I'm just not in the mood right off
I'm so bitter my question is I wanted to
know you're all about inspiration and
everything I've been feeling a little
bit unmotivated and I've been feeling
like I should be doing something or I
should be just I feel like I should be
pulled and like it isn't I'm feeling
uninspired basically that's my question
how do you get when you lose inspiration
and you lose motivation how do you get
it back I get it back by remembering
that we might die tomorrow that's true
so I'm inspired by practicality and
reality and the truth which is it is
ridiculously impossible to become a
human being
[Music]
hello all right so then or do you want
something techies like anyone I'll call
I'll go fast here so I really want to
understand the tech piece because in the
short term if I strategic ascendancy
land worth million then we just adjust
right yeah
all right cool thanks guys thanks chef
when we got - take a step back to
highlight they're coming up to me when
we're done I miss you wait until I have
other things going for me as a human
being and I'm just grateful you you're
dwelling and looking at what you don't
have versus looking at what you have if
you actually looked at what you had your
health you know living in America you
know who the heck knows what would be on
your list if you actually spend all your
time looking at that versus I don't have
a million dollars I'm not famous I don't
have this if you spent all your time of
what you have versus what you don't have
you will be the happiest girl on earth
the rest of the world is going to
critique you and judge you you need to
stop doing that for yourself
I'm worried I might miss take a step
back to the highlight they coming up to
me when we die - he waited to the
particle to highlight rich children in a
fantasy with my five five [ __ ] but she
just super Wi-Fi superficial she coming
with me cuz it's only yet the top of all
these high-rises and a don't Steve